y nueve días de cuarentena estricta para
la mayor parte de argentina así lo
anunció el presidente alberto fernández
vamos a restringir la circulación en
todas las zonas del país que se
encuadren en alto riesgo o en alarma
epidemiológica
la medida regirá desde este 22 de mayo a
las 0 horas hasta el domingo 30 de mayo
inclusive el confinamiento afectará a
gran parte del país
- algunas regiones en el norte de
argentina y en el sur de la capital
buenos aires- sólo funcionarán los
comercios esenciales y todas las
actividades presenciales se suspenderán
soy muy consciente
plenamente consciente de que estas
restricciones generan dificultades
ante esta realidad no queda más remedio
que escoger la preservación de la vida
desde inicios de abril el avance de la
pandemia en argentina no frena solo
durante la última semana se registraron
las cifras más altas de contagios y de
víctimas mortales desde el inicio de la
crisis sanitaria
el miércoles pasado más de 39 mil 600
personas fueron diagnosticadas con kobe
19 mientras que el martes 745 personas
perdieron la vida por el virus una cifra
récord en el país
la ocupación de camas de cuidados
intensivos en argentina ya supera el 70
por ciento mientras tanto la vacunación
no logra contener todavía la pandemia se
han administrado 10 7 millones de dosis
aunque sólo 2,2 millones de personas ya
están completamente inmunizadas en un
país de casi 45 millones de habitantes